who's the first uh
big name or big artist that we might
know that like gave you a cosign early
on
um like probably young doll
dolph that was the realest bro yeah
dolph been always silent
what year was that that probably was
like 2015
14. probably sooner than probably
earlier than that i can't really
remember but because i had did a song
with him
a long time ago but you know i was like
on some young [ __ ]
still one foot in one foot out so you
know he probably did a song with
millions of people
but he probably like what i'm thinking
happened is
with me keep going up like i kept going
and we ran into each other again and he
was like damn that's like a different
conversation it was difficult to say
like dan this
little buddy who you know what i'm
saying because back then i'll pay them
to cash them out for the verse yeah
y'all catch them out for the right i'll
pay them in all fives and tens like
trout money
so he already knew like back then so
when we ran into each other again he was
like damn he's still grinding
what was what was the the ticket on a
doll first back then
i think we're like i think i paid him
like eight thousand ten thousand
and then i paid him another ten for the
video though yeah you gotta double up
for the video
yeah y'all playing the team i was like
[ __ ] it like i used to love like giving
these
i used to look at everybody like rap
[ __ ] but now i i'm a rapper i hate
when somebody calls me a rotten egg
because i feel like kind of like
you trying to discredit somebody but
just because [ __ ] be rapping like that
me
they don't mean they ain't solid most of
these [ __ ] someone on silent no
not all of them
[Music]